stacked to the ceiling row upon row of
boxes packed full of lateral flow tests
ready and waiting at this warehouse in
nottinghamshire to be distributed to
pharmacies across the country
each individual box has almost 400 tests
in fact at this warehouse alone there
are tens of millions of tests all packed
up ready to go
it means while the country faced a
shortage of lateral flow kits these were
sitting ready to use
the first rapid tests manufactured in
the uk to be approved for self-use in
homes here but it took derby-based
company shawscreen around six months to
get that approval has that been
frustrating the length of time it's
taken especially in recent weeks when
you've seen the desperate need for
lateral blow fest in the country
well we just focus on making the best
test we can you know and
we're very aware of why regular
regulations are in place for several
weeks they've been loading lorries with
tests found for national distribution
centers but they've only appeared on
pharmacy shelves in the last few days
too late for those who've had to deal
with the national shortage it has been a
very difficult time for for pharmacies
in that for weeks we have been
highlighting that the demand is very
very high for lateral floor tests
however the supply is not matching the
demand and we're still in the same
situation that many pharmacies are
receiving very little
and some promises actually
don't get anything really a spokesperson
for the uk health security agency said
extensive evaluation is carried out on
tests designed for home use to ensure
they're reliable and accurate evaluation
of this data is part of the regulatory
approval process which can take time
they're able to produce around a million
tests a day here and already export them
to over 50 countries
some will question why it took so long
for them to be approved for home use
here becky johnson sky news
nottinghamshire